thank you very much but I have to have
to ask how many are here only because
you're on ashleymadison.com and
you just can't go home it says
ashleymadison.com
the online dating site for married
people who want to cheat like I have to
tell my audience
God hacked and they released it all like
37 million accounts they had and the
data
I love this it includes description of
what the members you know are looking
for things like a little anonymous fun
someone to cure my boredom looking to
kill time when my wife wife runs for
I don't know who that is and one of the
people they call it was Josh Duggar you
know Josh Duggar from the 19 and
Counting Duggar family the super
Christian family he had two accounts he
was cheating on his wife and he was
cheating on the woman he was cheating
with and in May remember this in May he
had to admit that he had been molesting
his sisters when he was a teenager I say
forget building a wall around Mexico
build one around Josh Duggar but on the
bright side subway has found a new
spokesman
Oh Jared come on trying to get with kids
and his wife divorced him already
he took those giant pants and threw him
right on the front line first Josh
gerrett we're all my heroes
Bill Cosby two more women came out today
now the list is over fifty there are
more Cosby accusers than shades of gray
and what is going on with Bill Cosby's
wife even Tammy Wynette has come on
doesn't anyone just [ __ ] anymore I mean
I'm a libertarian on sex issues but
tonight I'm just saying everybody here
needs to go home and have vanilla
missionary position Mitt Romney style
sex if the lights off and call each
other chuckles because and here's the
thing I love about the Ashley Madison
dump the most adulterous state in
America Alabama by far it killed every
other state Alabama and you know what
can't say they didn't warn us they said
when gay people get the right to marry
the Christians are going to go off [ __ ]
it just they're just all bets are off
there must be
must be so great to be an Evangelic Oh
Christian you know cuz and Jesus always
forgives but what you do I asked Jesus
forgive up there it is again
he said yes yeah yes I was in the ladies
room of a middle school banging a
chicken it was a moment of weakness
something something Satan let's move on
you know that and this is Josh Duggar's
second apology in three months and he
made a statement today this is what he
said I'm not I'm not this is not my
words he said I am the biggest hypocrite
ever because I espouse family values and
I'm a total pervert and that's why
tonight I would like to announce my
candidacy for the Republican nomination
Oh
oh the Republicans are tearing their
hair out first well this week bet first
off looks like the Iran deal Obama's
Iran deal is going to go through so so
rough here Iran deal gay marriage
Obamacare confirmed by the Supreme Court
and now doctors say the Trump that has
been growing inside them is inoperable
yes Donald Trump America's great orange
hope unveiled his immigration plan this
week and it is huge it's a three point
plan called Cinco goodbye oh and and
here at the plankton at repeal the 14th
amendment sees the wages of illegal
immigrants we're working here use that
money to build a wall and then deport
all 11 million of them is any of this
possible no but it gave millions of Fox
News viewers their first erection in
years
that makes what it brings this up about
Donald Trump who is always talking about
how we cannot have foreigners coming
into this country if ever his first wife
is from Czechoslovakia his current wife
is from Slovenia so if you think that
crawling under a wall is the most
disgusting way to become an American
somewhere there is a Panamanian woman
hiding in a truck full of chickens with
ten pounds of heroin filled condoms in
her stomach
who's thinking well at least I didn't
have to blow Donald Trump
you